- C'est un CHSLD pas comme
les autres. Il porte le nom
d'une polonaise célèbre,
Marie-Curie Sklodowska.
Mais ici, le tiers des
résidents, une quarantaine,
sont d'origine ukrainienne.
Dans la grande salle,
la télévpas de répit.
Polonais et Ukrainiens,
résidents et employés
sont unis dans l'épreuve.
- Deux millions d'Ukrainiens...
- Deux millions et demi, déjà.
GENOWEFA BOCHNIAK, infi. aux.,
CHSLD Marie-Curie Slodowska
- Ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui me... ouf...
- J'appartiens à une famillemélu
moins... un peu moins polonais.
- À 95 ans, Eugène Antonyszyn
est immunodéprimé et ne peut
sortir de sa chambre, mais
ses souvenirs lui tiennent
compagnie.
EUGENE ANTONYSZYN, résident,
CHSLD Marie-Curie Sklodowska
- Les bombardements,
tout ça là, j'ai tout vécu.
Ça a duré jusqu'en 1945.
Quand j'étais en Allemagne,
on mangeet chaque
jour, on était mal nourris.
- Il a été prisonnier et mis
au travail forcé pendant deuxaÀn
de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
il devient soldat pour lesAméri.
Il arrive à Montréal en 1951.
- J'étais médecin en ukraine,
tous mes amis habitent là-bas,
mes parents, les parents
de mon mari.
- Elle-même inquiète pour
ses proches, Maryna Symenovych,
soigne ceux chez qui la guerre
a réveillé des souvenirs
douloureux.
MARYNA SYMENOVYCH, inf. aux.
CHSLD Marie-Curie Slodowska
- De savoir que c'est la guerre
entre l'Ukraine et les Russes,
mais c'est difficile.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS FORTIN VERREAULT,
pdg, CIUSSS de l'Est-de-l'Île
- Pour nos résidents, par
exemple, certains ont connu
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
fait que ça ramène
des souvenirs, ils ont encore
des membres de la famillelà-bas.
- La direction du CIUSSS de
l'Est-de-l'Île-de-Montréal
est sensible à l'impact
de l'invasion russe dans
cet établissement.OLGA IVANYUTA,
Marie-Curie Slodowska
- Le climat de travail est
vraiment difficile parce
qu'on doit prendre soin de nous
autres, des résidents, donc
on doit quand même continuer.
Et, je suis fière de mes
employés parce qu'ils continuent
de travailler même en pleurant.
- Il se donne ici des leçons
d'entraide et de p.......
- C'est le sentiment très
intense. C'est comme le stress,
la peur, en même temps l'espoir,
la fierté de notre pays, parce
que maintenant tout le monde
comprend qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire les Ukrainiens.
Ce n'est pas les R
- La Pologne, ils ont fait
un geste formidable!
Merci beaucoup Polonais!
Ils sont avec nous
savent, les Polonais,
que si les Ukrainiens vont
lâcher, la prochaine ça va
être la Pologne.
- Très lucide, Eugene Antonyszyn
préfère parler de politique
plutôt que de douleur et
de tristesse.- Naturellement nos
pas aussi forts que la Russie,
mais apparemment la Russie,
ils ont des problèmes avec
nous, ils sont pas capables
de nous mettre à genoux.
- Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Mon